[Música]
[Aplausos]
se cumplen y por eso yo estoy acá hoy
cuando yo aprendí a tocar guitarra hace
un montón de tiempo
en vez de
en vez de tratar de sacar la canción que
estaba de moda una canción que me
gustaba
empecé a crear mis propias melodías
y empecé a escribir mis propias
canciones era algo que me salía natural
y era muy muy satisfactorio y desde
entonces siento una gran pasión por la
música y un gran una gran admiración por
la actividad creativa y por los
creadores
en aquel momento cuando
yo estaba empezando no habían muchos
lugares en los cuales yo podía
presentarme conseguir teatros era algo
relativamente difícil y lo único que
tenía a mano eran bares boliches
estos lugares no estaban necesariamente
bien acondicionados
para lo que yo quería hacer cuando
habían luces y sonidos generalmente eran
insuficientes
además de eso tenía que ser el boletero
el barrendero el productor
el jefe de prensa el mánager el contador
el vestuarista el iluminador en fin
cualquier persona
cualquier persona que haya emprendido
sabrá de qué hablo cuando hay que hacer
todo todo al mismo tiempo era difícil
pero yo me bajaba del escenario
contentos porque estar en un escenario
me llena de alegría sin embargo siempre
me quedaba el bichito siempre había algo
que podía haber hecho mejor siempre hay
algo que podía haber hecho de manera
diferente incluso cuando empecé a tocar
en otras ciudades
me puse me di cuenta que la situación
era muy parecida en otros lugares
entonces salió mi primera conclusión
había que crear más y mejores escenarios
un tiempo después con esa misma idea en
mente nos juntamos con un grupo de
gestores y artistas creamos un colectivo
al cual muy creativamente le llamamos el
colectivo
entonces empezamos a crear escenarios
tomamos el museo de arte tomamos plazas
parques todos los lugares que podíamos y
crearemos escenarios para los artistas
locales y los artistas nacionales
nosotros incluidos por supuesto las
dinámicas que ese género fue tan linda
que tu impacto a nivel nacional artistas
de rock de pop de funk de rap ustedes
imagínense la cantidad de géneros
musicales tuvieron mayores oportunidades
de acceder a un escenario y el público
tenía mayor oportunidad de conocerlos a
los artistas y de seguir a quienes les
gustaba este trabajo lo hacíamos
jalan los fondos públicos y
desafortunadamente los recortes en los
presupuestos de culturas poco a poco se
fueron llevando uno a uno de esos
proyectos que fuimos creando el último
espectáculo el último show que ofrecimos
fue en febrero del 2016 después de seis
años de trabajo generando escenarios
para artistas
el final de esa etapa me dejó pensando
en algo que
que me venía dando vueltas en la cabeza
desde hacía mucho tiempo como alcanzamos
la sostenibilidad es decir habíamos
creado escenarios sin embargo eso no era
suficiente nuestro colectivo dependía
económicamente de un tercero que nos
podía dejar colgado que fue finalmente
lo que sucedió y entonces estábamos a la
deriva sin embargo el desafío era probar
que la creatividad el arte y la cultura
podían generar valores económicos
obviamente yo sé que a ustedes les dirán
siempre nos han dicho a todos que el
arte no da que te vas a morir de hambre
que la cultura no se puede que es
difícil en fin
ese era el desafío probar que un
emprendimiento cultural creativo era
viable en esta ciudad y en este país
tiempo después fue muy grato para mí
descubrir que había más gente en esa
sintonía en un concierto donde más
podría haber sido conocí a unas personas
empezamos a discutir empezamos a charlar
nos reunimos durante semanas y después
de un tiempo nació ver aquí verá que es
una palabra una palabra griega que
significa ponerle el alma a las cosas o
hacer las cosas o imprimir el alma en
las cosas que uno hace esta palabra no
sólo sirvió de nombre para el proyecto
sino también sirvió como un lema para
todos los que trabajamos en él
el concepto no era nada novedoso los
café concert café son tan algunos les
llaman existen en europa desde el siglo
18 algunos dicen que hasta son
anteriores y en muchas ciudades del
mundo son bastante comunes sin embargo
lo que queríamos era poner el escenario
a disposición de los artistas para que
ellos puedan ofrecer el juego que
siempre soñaron a su público queríamos
ser el semillero para artistas nuevos ya
no dependíamos de nadie ya no
dependíamos de ningún tercero podíamos
hacer deshacer y rehacer sin embargo
todos los que emprenden saben que no
solo de ponerle el alma a las cosas se
vive para que el proyecto tenga éxito
tenía que ser también sostenible vuelve
el desafío
entonces empezamos un proceso de
fórmulas buscar la fórmula con la cual
la magia tenía que suceder y créanme la
magia también sucede tiene que suceder
en la gestión teníamos que buscar y
encontrar la forma en la cual el espacio
tenía que funcionar y que los artistas
pudieran hacer dibujos libre en nuestro
escenario
la fórmula fueron vinieron todavía van y
vienen porque seguimos en un proceso de
experimentación pero había algo que
siempre saltaba a la vista en cada éxito
y en cada fracaso teníamos que ser
cómplices de nuestros artistas y los
artistas tenían que ser nuestros socios
principales en esta complicidad sociedad
nosotros hacíamos la gestión vendíamos
las entradas hacíamos las reservas
organizábamos limpiábamos coordinábamos
para que el espacio estuviera limpio
operativo preparado con el equipo
técnico ya sea para ensayos para montaje
o para la ejecución de un show para
pruebas de sonido también en fin
hacíamos un poco de difusión también
tratábamos de conectar con el público
con los medios de prensa hacíamos todo
ese trabajo que para muchos de nosotros
es invisible pero es fundamental para
que un espectáculo funcione para que ese
espectáculo sea un éxito
esta complicidad hizo que empezáramos a
ampliar las opciones de nuestro
escenario empezamos a recibir obras de
teatro proyecciones de películas
documentales presentaciones del libro
shows de comedia en fin un montón de
cosas que nos hicieron descubrir que en
nuestra ciudad hay mucho talento que
está buscando escenarios hay mucha gente
que quiere compartir actividades
culturales actividades creativas y así
apareció un nuevo desafío
teníamos una gran variedad de
actividades teníamos una gran variedad
de propuestas pero no siempre la sala
estaba llena
evidentemente habían algunos artistas
que fueron un éxito inmediato hubieron
otros que empezaron a crecer y poco a
poco hemos ido como hemos ido viendo
cómo evolucionaban hasta llegar a donde
están ahora
y ahí es donde
viene la parte que le corresponde al
artista en esta sociedad complicidad que
hace el artista o mejor dicho que
debería ser el artista que tiene las
alas llenas
en este tiempo hemos identificado tres
cosas que son sencillas pero muy
importantes
crear constantemente el artista que está
creando constantemente siempre puede
arrancarle un huevo a su público y ese
público siempre va a querer volver para
dejarse sorprender
conectar con el público
el artista que conecta con el público
tiene una convocatoria increíble
sabe cuáles son las cosas que le
arrancan ese guau al público y trabaja
sobre ellas para que el artista para que
el público vuelva para que el público
siempre se sorprendan
esta es muy importante aceptan y hacen
el trabajo que no les gusta con la parte
que no les gusta de su trabajo ustedes
saben que todos los trabajos tienen su
lado oscuro
llamémosle más bien su lado aburrido ya
les dije la magia no solo tiene que
ocurrir en el escenario también tiene
que ocurrir en la gestión
uno tiene que saber cuánto gana cuánto
gasta uno tiene que sentarse a
planificar a corto a mediano a largo
plazo producir un espectáculo no sólo
implica pensar en lo que pasa en el
escenario el trabajo del artista no sólo
ocurre frente al público
en este camino como emprendedor como
artista he descubierto estos tres pasos
que son fundamentales y que quiero
compartir hoy con ustedes
soñar pensar y visualizar
donde quiero estar que quiero hacer como
artista como emprendedor como empresario
arriesgar salir de la zona de confort
para probar nuestras tesis nuestras
teorías nuestras ideas lanzarte a
demostrarle a los demás tu convicción
de mostrarle tu amor
y tu fe en lo que hace
y tres
mucho mucho mucho mucho
utilizando tus sueños como una brújula y
tu riesgo como un motivador constante
y entonces
se van a animar
[Aplausos]